now that you've created your repository
on github and it has some commits let's
take a look at what this looks like on
the github website like in the create
your own adventure repository I can see
what files are in the repository also
scrolling back up I can view the commit
history by clicking on commits this is
similar to running git log on the
command line but it shows the history of
the repository on github rather than
showing the history of your local
repository so you'll only see changes
that have been pushed to github it's
also possible to create and edit plain
text files directly on the github
website right now I just pushed from my
local repository to github so they have
the same content but I'm going to add
some content directly on github so that
you can see what happens when you have
changes on github that aren't present in
your local repository in practice this
can happen if you make the changes
directly on github but it can also
happen if you push changes to get hub
from another computer or if there's
another person working on your project
who pushes changes to github to create a
new file I'll click this plus sign I'm
going to create a file for my lesson
three reflections and I'll add the first
reflection prompt you'll be seeing this
prompt pretty soon now I'll scroll down
and here I can enter a commit message
the message should go in the first box
and I can use this second box if I want
to add a longer description of my commit
but I'll leave that blank now on the
right side of the screen I can click
commit new file now I can see that a new
commit has been created create file for
lesson three and add first reflection
now I'll demonstrate pulling these
changes down to my local repository in a
minute but first I want you to create a
new reflections file on github so that
you can follow along you'll see some
instructions about how to do that on the
next screen